[Música]
hola soy Juli Riaño
sobre los hechos que marcaron la agenda
durante 2021 en nuestro continente
[Música]
si bien la migración en el mundo no es
un fenómeno nuevo si es una realidad más
mediática desde hace algunos años
durante el 2021 eventos migratorios
masivos en la región volvieron a poner
el foco en la cuestión sobre la
movilidad humana la migración en
caravana solos represamiento son las
fronteras las muertes durante el
tránsito y las medidas de los gobiernos
para conseguir la avanzada se tomaron
varios titulares y la pandemia no fue
impedimento para que me lees emprenderán
el camino hacia mejores oportunidades
así América Latina fue un corredor
migratorio importante durante el año
para un tránsito impulsado por la
llegada de un nuevo gobierno Estados
Unidos y la necesidad por mejores
condiciones de vida según la
Organización Internacional para las
Migraciones de los
281 millones de migrantes
internacionales en el mundo unos 59
millones están en América del Norte y
14,8 en América Latina y el Caribe
cuando las restricciones de movilidad
por la pandemia de covid-19 comenzaron a
relajarse el flujo de migrantes
erreaktibo y el 2021 evidenció un
tránsito masivo desconocido hasta ese
momento proveniente de Chile y Brasil
miles de haitianos se movilizaron por
Sur y Centroamérica buscando llegar a
Estados Unidos en este caso no se trata
de personas que salieron de su país de
nacimiento sino de migrantes que volvían
a emigrar una crisis calificada como
predecible por algunos analistas pero
invisibilizada durante años veamos cómo
fue ese tránsito en el informe de Álvaro
cordero
recorrer todo un continente en búsqueda
de una vida mejor ese pretexto era la
razón por la que miles de haitianos
recorrieron gran parte de América
durante el 2021 estas personas vivían
mayoritariamente en Chile y Brasil allí
llegaron tras el terremoto que devastó
Haití en 2010 pero apenas se les dio una
oportunidad una situación que sumada a
la pandemia les obligo a partir hacia el
norte esto supone recorrer miles de
kilómetros a lo largo de Sudamérica y
atravesar numerosos países y pasos
naturales extremadamente peligrosos como
el tapón del Darien en el límite entre
Colombia y Panamá una barrera
prácticamente impenetrable para los
migrantes que tienen el objetivo de
llegar a la frontera sur de Estados
Unidos precisamente a las puertas del
tapón del Darien fue donde se vivió una
de las primeras crisis en la pequeña
localidad colombiana de Necoclí miles de
migrantes se agolparon durante meses en
condiciones muy malas y cuando
conseguían partida hacía Panamá quedaron
a la naturaleza y de peligrosos grupos
armados un riesgo alto que algunos
optaron por asumir unos 90.000 según
datos de autoridades colombianas y
muchos perdieron la vida en el intento
la mayoría de ellos se instaló debajo de
un puente fronterizo hasta que las
deportaciones masivas hay Pi comenzaron
haciendo que el esfuerzo de estas
personas por huir de la pobreza extrema
no sirviera para nada
con una frontera cerrada los que no
fueron deportados comenzaron su vuelta a
México un país donde ahora muchos
intentan instalarse pero en el que
todavía persiste una crisis migratoria
que has acudido a todo el continente
y precisamente en México concentra un
importante número de migrantes que
esperan cruzar a Estados Unidos el
anuncio de apertura de las fronteras por
parte de Washington durante los últimos
meses del año y lusiona a varios pero lo
cierto fue que los límites no fueron
abierto para sus casos en particular en
enero la llegada de una nueva
administración demócrata impulso la
formación de nuevas caravanas de
migrantes y aunque el gobierno de Joe
Biden insistió en que no era momento
para emprender el viaje en 2021 fue
calificado como uno de los años más
intensos para la movilidad por los más
de 3000 kilómetros de frontera entre
EEUU y México
la crisis migratoria que vive
Centroamérica volvió a ser protagonista
en el 2021 miles de personas intentaron
marchar hacia Estados Unidos en varias
caravanas de migrantes la primera gran
movilización de personas llego con el
año miles de hondureños partieron hacia
el norte por dos grandes causas la
primera la esperanza de que la llegada
al poder de Joe Weider en Estados Unidos
se tradujera en una política migratoria
más laxa la segunda la gran destrucción
que sufrió Honduras por los huracanes
bellota
[Música]
higo casa todo en 2021 se comprobó como
estas caravanas tienen cada vez más
difícil llegar a la frontera
estadounidense debido a su política de
externalización de fronteras la mayoría
de migrantes parten de ciudades como San
Pedro Sula o Tegucigalpa pero a los
pocos kilómetros se encuentra en una
fuerte oposición en la frontera
guatemalteca los que logran pasar lo
hacen por caminos ilegales pero en la
frontera entre México y Guatemala
reciben un rechazo todavía más fuerte en
su intento por cruzar las fronteras las
fuerzas policiales de Guatemala y México
protagonizaron cargas muy violentas
contra los migrantes que dejaron escenas
caóticas y dificultaron el avance de
estas caravanas cuyos miembros en muchos
casos se vieron agotados quiero seguir
con mis hijas mi mamá me dice sigamos no
te entregues porque sí la verdad que ya
me estaban dando ganas de entregarme
porque ya no aguanto me duele mucho mis
piernas y mi hija igual andar hasta con
ampollas en los pies mi mamá igual pero
ya me dice no hija si vamos si vamos
adelante no te vayas entregarme
familia salen de sus hogares por varios
motivos durante los últimos años la
violencia de las maras en Honduras y El
Salvador se ha multiplicado
provocando cientos de asesinatos anuales
la cuestión de la inseguridad sumada a
la de la gran crisis económica que sufre
Honduras son las razones de su búsqueda
desesperada por salir del país aunque
son conscientes de los riesgos que
entraña partir hacia Estados Unidos
muchos de ellos lo siguieron haciendo
especialmente en el último tramo del año
que me falle está está en López en la
peor situación económica
delincuencia
hambruna no hay estudios y educación
para los cipotes por eso tomamos la
determinación yo y mi esposa de venirnos
pues para para ver si si podemos lograr
nuestro objetivo
con las fronteras cada vez más difíciles
de atravesar la duda ahora gira en torno
a que el cambio de gobierno en Honduras
y la llegada de ayudas económicas logren
que la situación mejore para la
ciudadanía
durante los primeros meses de la
administración Vall d'en en Estados
Unidos se rompieron todos los récords en
cuanto a la llegada de migrantes a sus
fronteras y más de 1,7 millones de
personas fueron detenidas hasta
septiembre de 2021 el registro triplica
los datos de los últimos años ante tales
llegarás Washington o mantuvo una serie
de medidas del Gobierno Trump el título
42 que permite las devoluciones por
cuestiones sanitarias y quédate en
México que obliga a los migrantes a
esperar una respuesta a sus solicitudes
en ese país y el tránsito de los
migrantes venezolanos por la región no
se detuvo durante 2021 aunque Colombia
sigue como su principal destino silencio
llegar por su frontera norte a miles de
ellos las autoridades chilenas
registraron más de 25000 ingresos por el
desierto de Atacama actualmente los
países de América Latina y el Caribe
acogen a más de
4990000 venezolanos esa es la situación
estos migrantes venezolanos están
atravesando una de las regiones más
áridas del planeta sin prácticamente
nada la frontera entre Bolivia y Chile
ha visto como en los últimos meses el
paso de ciudadanos procedentes de
Venezuela ha aumentado en 2021 todos
ellos huyen de la pobreza extrema y el
hambre que sigue sufriendo su país y
tienen como objetivo Chile la mayoría
llegan a la ciudad de Iquique dónde se
instalan en la calle en condiciones
pésimas
en realidad venimos de Colombia tenemos
un primo un mes y el 4
el 4 de noviembre y llegamos aquí el
primero de diciembre por los momentos en
las carpas estamos bien pero cuando
llegamos que dormimos así a la
interperie ya había un poquito de frío
además de esas penurias estas personas
sufren en rechazo de muchos de los
habitantes locales hace tan solo unos
meses se organizo una protesta contra
los migrantes de la ciudad y se logro
desalojar un campamento
este fuerte rechazo ha hecho que muchos
opten por vivir fuera de la ciudad en
pleno desierto aquí viven con lo básico
pero al menos gozan de tranquilidad
nos ofrecieron fue unos terrenos aquí y
decidimos subir en abril
pero un porcentaje muy pequeño de los
que
solamente
subimos en 2020 los números de migrantes
que salieron de Venezuela se redujeron a
causa de la pandemia pero en este 2021
ante la reapertura de fronteras estos
flujos han vuelto a aumentar en busca de
una vida mejor en otras naciones
latinoamericanas
sobre el caso particular de los
migrantes venezolanos Colombia dio un
paso positivo y anunció el estatus
temporal de protección un permiso por 10
años que beneficiará a más de 1,7
millones de personas un gesto que
contrasta en un año de muchas
restricciones
el anuncio de Colombia de otorgar
protección temporal a los venezolanos
que se encuentran en su territorio por
un período de 10 años es un gesto
humanitario emblemático para la región
como usted existe
inclusive para el mundo entero
está iniciativa es una extraordinaria
muestra de humanizar
compromiso con los derechos humanos y y
pragmatismo
durante el segundo año el covid 19 en el
mundo la pandemia disminuyó los flujos
migratorios según la OCDE pero también
hizo la situación de los que se alejaron
de casa de ahí que muchos de los que ya
habían migrado lo intentarán de nuevo
hacia un nuevo destino
especial sobre la migración en América
Latina que preparamos junto Álvaro
cordero gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos durante el 2021 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con hashtag migrantes es 24
siguen con más información en France 24
y France 24.com
[Música]